يسعدني أن ألتقي بك ،
أنا بخير ، كيف حالك ، تهانينا
على الفيلم ،
شكرًا لك أنا شخصياً أحب الفيلم ،
إنه ممتع ، إنه ممتع ، لقد كنت مضحكًا
للغاية وشعرت برغبة في تصويره ، كان هناك
الكثير من الضحك أثناء تصوير الفيلم
كان هذا هو الحال  نعم ، لقد فعلنا ذلك ، لقد
تأثرنا بالضحكات
قليلاً أه
أعتقد أننا أهدرنا الكثير من
الوقت والمال ، أنا متأكد من الضحك فقط في
المجموعة ولكن هذا أيضًا ما أرادوه ،
وهذا ما أرادوه netflix
الكيمياء  أن لدينا خارج الشاشة
التي عرفناها جميعًا بعضنا البعض
لسنوات عديدة دواين وجول وأنا ، لقد
أرادوا ذلك على الشاشة وهذا ما
حصلوا عليه للأفضل أو الأسوأ كان
هذا هو الشيء المفضل لدينا ، نعم الشيء المفضل لدينا
كان  والسبب في
وجودنا جميعًا هو العمل معًا
وقضاء بعض الوقت مع أصدقائنا ، لذا عند
الحديث عن الكيمياء بينك
وبين دوان ، من الواضح جدًا كما قلت
أمام الكاميرا وكان من الواضح
أنه بعيدًا عن الكاميرا
علاقة شخصية سألناه
عنها في الواقع عنك منذ أيام قليلة
وقال أشياء كثيرة كان علينا في
الواقع أن نسمع صوتها ، لذا
سأعطيك الكلمة الآن ماذا لديك
لتقوله عنها ،
واو آه ليس لدي  فكرة أن دواين
صعب عليّ وهذا أه هذا
أه لا شك أنه كان صعبًا عليّ لكن آه
هذا جيد تمامًا إنه من حقه أن يفعل
ذلك
أعتقد أنني حصلت على أفضل ما لديه في
معظم الفيلم لذا أنا "  أنا متأكد الآن في
جولة الترويجي أنه سيذهب
ورائي وأعتقد أنه يجب أن أستحق ذلك ،
هل تعتقد أنك تفعل
حسنًا ،
هل كان ذلك مصدر قلق لك على
الإطلاق لأنك ترغب في التمثيل معه في
فيلم له  كونك رمز الحركة مثل
أيقونة فيلم الحركة كما لو كنت
تشعر بالقلق من أن الناس قد يضعونك في الواقع
بالمقارنة معه ،
لا أعتقد أن هناك أي طريقة
لمقارنتي مع دواين روك جونسون ،
أعني إذا كنت سأقف بعد ذلك  بالنسبة له
الثالث ، لا يوجد أي مجال للمقارنة على الإطلاق ، فإن الرجل
هو جبلي مغطى بالجلد
ن واه وأيضًا تعلمون
خلافًا لما سيقوله لكم
إنه رجل نبيل في الواقع ، إنه في الواقع
أحد السادة العظماء في هذا
المجال ، لذا أحببت العمل معه
وهذا رائع ، هذا الفيلم ممتع
ومضحك وهناك كوميديا ولكنه أي
ًا  فيلم أكشن مناسب ، كان هناك بعض
الأعمال المثيرة الرائعة ، مدى صعوبة التصوير
الذي
تعرفه ،
إن الأشياء المثيرة على ما يرام.
كان الأمر أكثر
كلما كان الحوار هو الشيء الذي أشعر
بقلق أكبر بشأنه ، فأنا أميل إلى معرفة أحب
اللعب بنكات أه
مختلفة ولحظات مختلفة في الفيلم ، وكان
هذا هو الشيء الذي
كنت أركز عليه بشكل أساسي  كنت تقوم بأفلام الحركة
لحسن الحظ منذ أكثر من 20 عامًا ، لذا
أشعر براحة تامة في عالم الألعاب المثيرة
، إنها تتعلق أكثر بالأشياء الأخرى ،
لذا دعني آخذك إلى أه في
الواقع خلال العامين الماضيين
والوباء الطمع الذي كنا عليه
أه جميعًا يحبون العيش ، لذا فكيف كان الأمر يشبه
تصوير فيلم خلال تلك الفترة
الجيدة ، توقفنا عن التصوير عندما ضرب الوباء
كنا ، وكنا أيضًا من
أوائل الأفلام التي عادت إلى الوراء ، وأنا
ممتن حقًا لأن Netflix وجدت
طريقة لنا  أن نعود بأمان وبأمان
بطريقة أه كنا جميعًا قادرين على البقاء
بصحة جيدة في وضع العمل والعمل من خلاله
وأم هل يمكن أن تقول
أنه كان صعبًا هل كان مختلفًا
تمامًا مع جميع الاحتياطات للطمع
وكل من
هذا صعب لأنني معتاد جدًا على
وجود علاقة مع الطاقم.
أحب الطاقم وأحب العمل مع الأشخاص
في جميع الأقسام وأنت تعلم عندما يكون
الجميع مغطى بالكتلة
والدروع ، فأنت لا تملك حقًا هذا
الاتصال الشخصي  لكن بالنسبة إلى فريق التمثيل ،
لم يتغير شيء بمجرد أن نكون في المجموعة
نفسها ، كان كل شيء على ما هو عليه في
العادة ، لقد كان محاطًا
بظروف مختلفة كثيرًا من الواضح ،
لذا ما الذي شعرت به الآن
مع العرض العالمي الأول  هنا
بعد عامين من السرية ، ما الذي
شعرت به كان رائعًا 2 لقد
أوقفت قبعتي أمام Netflix الذي وضع بالفعل
حدثًا ضخمًا
للعرض الأول لم أصدق أنه
لم أحضر عرضًا أول مثل هذا منذ سنوات  أو
حقًا ، ولكن حقيقة أنهم
قادرون على القيام بذلك الآن ، شعرت حقًا أننا
كنا نعود إلى حد ما إلى طبيعته ، لذلك
هذا هو كل الوقت الذي
أمضيته معك ، لذا شكرًا جزيلاً لك ،
تهانينا حقًا للدردشة معك
وطيب  حظ شكرا لك